um
[Music]
we got a question today about salah or
as some people call it namaz
so sallah or namaz there are different
types for example
there are the five daily prayers the
five obligatory prayers fajr
dohr maghrib and isha these are five you
must pray
there's also sunnah prayers that you can
pray for example you could pray two raka
for sunnah before salat al-fajr
you could pray two raka sunnah after
salah
and i will show you guys on the screen a
list of them
so when it comes to praying the five
obligatory prayers
the five fathered prayers you can see
is the dawn prayer you have until
sunrise
until the sun starts to rise and thus
until the sun starts to come up
you have until then to praise salatul
fajr
if you don't get it in then then you've
missed fajr
for dr
you have until the next one comes so for
example it's it's 12 30 pm
and salatul dohr just started you don't
pray
and then it comes to three o'clock and
now it's slaughtered
since salat al-asr has started you've
missed if you didn't pray it
same thing let's say the sun goes down
and it's maghrib and you didn't pray
asur
now you've missed salah let's say now
it's 9 p.m
and it's salah asha now you've missed
salat and maghrib
so until the next one comes you have to
pray that prayer
but for isha if you take the full length
of the night
and divide it by two that's what a
majority of scholars say is the window
to praise salah
and others say you have until midnight
but the lesson of today pray salah
your salah as soon as it comes if it's
pray right away
if it's us pray right away don't wait
don't say well i have until this time go
pray right away
do not delay do not prolong it just a
quick recap
so for for salat you have until sunrise
for doha you have until for us
you have until the half of the night is
done
or some scholars stay till 12 o'clock
but pray them asap
now the sunnah prayers again i will put
up the
picture you guys could see take a
screenshot of this look it up
these are the sunnahs of the prophet saw
islam in what he would pray
now there's also night prayers
200 prayers prayers at night time the
prophet
on average he would pray 8 so 2 2
2 and 2 as far as i know for a total of
eight
and the prayer and the dua of tahajud is
like an arrow that doesn't miss so if
you pray
to hajjud prayer like the prophet salam
and you make dua
it will be accepted in sha allah in the
last third of the night
best time to pray and make dua or one of
the best times
after slaughter asha the prophet
he would pray his turaka after salah and
he would pray two for forgiveness and
then
he would pray well there's i've heard
different opinions
one for water it's just to end off after
you've done praying
all your praise for the day you can pray
one rakah for witter
and then you're done for the day and i
know the question comes up if i pray my
witter and then i want to pray more can
i yes you can
if you want to but what it is supposed
to be the last prayer of the day
so that being said five prayers
fajr doher mandatory
you must pray these the sunnah prayers
they're optional
they are optional so the two rakat
before fajr you could that's optional
it's really good to pray it but it's
optional you will not be punished for
not praying sunnah
you will not be punished for not praying
water but fajr
doher if you do not pray these
you will possibly be punished by allah
so make sure you get them in
and if you pray them you will be
rewarded inshallah with that being said
hope this video was helpful i hope it
answered the question
if you guys have any other questions let
us know insha allah and we will make
videos like this
to cover them
has
[Music]
foreign um
[Music]